- Les chefs ont fait
de nombreuses affirmations ce
soir, mais ont-ils dit toute la
vérité? Voici notre vérification
des faits, avec Olivier Bachand.
GABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, co-porte-
parole, Québec solidaire
- Savez vous que le Toyota RAV
4, on en vend 24 fois plus que
le Dodge Caravan et pourtant ce
véhicules là ne sera pas touché
par notre plan.
- Oui, c'est vrai.
Le Toyota RAV 4 ne serait pas
touché par la taxe de 15 % sur
l'achat de véhicules neufs de
Québec solidaire, parce que ses
émissions polluantus
faibles que le seuil établi
par la formation politique.
En 2021, le modèle a en effet
été vendu 24 fois plus
que le Dodge Caravan.
Mais l'immense majorité des
fourgonnettes, des camionnettes
et des véhicules utilitaires
sport seraient touchés.
ÉRIC DUHAIME, chef, Parti
conservateur du Québec
- On voudrait réduire de 5000
le nombre d'employés de l'État.
On voudrait fonctinner
par atrrition, mais on veut
réduire la taille de l'État.
Contrairement à M. Legault,
on ne veut pas promettre une
chose et faire le contraire
comme M. Legault.
- C'est vrai.
En 2018, la CAQ avait promis
de supprimer 5000 postes par
attrition au sein de la fonction
publique. Mais le nombre de
fonctionnaires a plutôt grimpé
de près de 15 % entre mars 2017
et mars 2021, pour atteindre
plus de 55 000.
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE
cheffe, Parti libéral du Québec
- M. Legault il aime beaucoup se
comaprer à l'Ontario, mais on a
créé trois fois moins, il a
trois fois moins d'emplois que
l'Ontario. Mais c'est vrai. M.
Legault.
- C'est vrai, mais elle ne dit
pas tout.
L'Ontario a créé  469 000
depuis octobre 2018,
c'est trois fois plus que le
Québec, qui en a créé 156 000
pendant la même période.
Mais il ne faut pas oublier que
l'Ontario est beaucoup plus
populeuse. Par ailleurs, depuis
que la CAQ est au pouvoir, le
Québec a créé 17 % des emplois
au pays, alors que la province
compte pour 23 % de la
population canadienne.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT
chef, Coalition avenir Québec
- Est-ce que vous admettez qu'il
y a eu moins de décès au Québec?
- M. Legualt, on a plus de morts
par capita que partout au
Canada.
- C'est une affirmation qui
mérite des nuances.
er, le taux de mortalité
lié à la COVID-19 est en effet
plus élevé au Québec qu'ailleurs
au Canada .
Mais selon plusieurs experts,
c'est parce que la province
mieux répertorié les décès liés
à la COVID-19.
Depuis l la pandémie,
les données montrent que la
surmortalité a été plus faible
au Québec que dans l'ensemble du
pays, laissant croire que moins
de gens y seraient décédés de la
COVID.
- Moi je suis content de dir
qu'on a triplé depuis quatre ans
le nombre de classe de
maternelles quatre ans.
- C'est vrai, mais il ne dit
tout.
Le nombre de classes de
maternelles 4 ans a pratiquement
quadrupl018 pour
atteindre 1600.
Mais l'engagement de la CAQ
était d'ouvrir 5200 classes dans
un horizon de cinq ans, unobjecé
réduit de moitié.